bonjour je suis jean daniel youtube le
créateur de youtube ici des millions de
vidéos sont postées chaque mois
n'utilisez pas bloc vos cachets monsieur
merci je suis très fier de mon
entreprise je tiens à vous faire visiter
youtube c'est d'abord les changes entre
le créateur et les internautes à travers
les commentaires que l espace d échanges
formidables d'isolement un commentaire
cette vidéo c'est de la merde j'ai perdu
deux minutes de ma vie un autre compte
venez voir ma chaîne je fais des vidéos
sur minecraft un autre il fait ça que
pour l'argent disais moi un commentaire
sur méchanceté ni promo à coulx la vidéo
formidable mettant un coup derrière moi
aussi je fais des vidéos nous adorons
nos créateurs d'ailleurs sur la page
d'accueil de notre site nous mettons en
avant de nombreux nouveaux youtuber qui
mérite d'être connue car il propose du
contenu riche et varié mais qui
aujourd'hui en page d'accueil
squeeze demain squeeze après demain
quizy ensuite weezy suite à cela
squeeze pour changer squeeze jamais
entendu parler d'eux oui si comme le dit
souvent sandrine anissa nous adorons nos
créateurs bonjour je suis auto ni de
carton jaune sur votre pare-brise est à
la mode il faut 500
le résultat est presque invisible et
votre pare-brise retrouve sa solide
souvent boussehaba la pointe de la
technologie
une de mes fiertés les sous titres
automatique vous lisez quoi la catapulte
données chez nous vous êtes embauché à
je suis pas peu fier de mon truc
monsieur youtube j'ai un problème voilà
j'ai envie de faire des vidéos sur
youtube sauf que j'ai pas d'idée
absolument aucun talent mais ça ce n'est
pas un problème bien au contraire
merci monsieur youtube beaucoup de
potentiel nous avons des vidéos pour
tous les goûts vous aimez les jeux vidéo
il ya tout le monde super-g/descente
audio sont tous trois simulateurs de
shiro je serai comme samir geagea lors
de ces parties à prendre
oui par contre monsieur sous l'écran est
éteint je prends le scalpel alors déjà
d'accord le jeu malgré directement ya
plein de 104,2 de s'écouler méchant
malade fait mal on va essayer de
récupérer avec le marteau tout
l'excellent no you tube aux beautés ont
beaucoup de talent aujourd'hui on attend
quelques secondes aventures stalter si
vous voulez bonjour je suis au coni de
carglass un seul impact sur votre
pare-brise et l amour dans secousses
c'est la catastrophe
avec notre résine spéciale que nous
injectons en moins de 30 minutes le
résultat est presque invisible et votre
pare-brise retrouve cette solidité et le
plus souvent l'hypertension
j'avais choisi par garbo faire gaffe et
bah oui il ya beaucoup de vidéos de
cuisine on adore
et maintenant il ne me restait plus qu'à
enfourner à 300 degrés celsius pendant
trois heures de ce que la fille de tout
sur youtube j'ai un problème voilà en
fait j'étais zune music de rihanna de
trois secondes dans ma vidéo et elle a
été supprimée
qu'est-ce que vous avez une solution
trois secondes tu dis plus jamais tu
utilises une musique quand t'as pas les
droits
notre nouveauté désormais nous
n'attendons plus que vous fassiez le
buzz nous le créons nous mêmes désolé
monsieur mais le chat ne veux pas peser
a ajouté le chercher le bébé sa place
vous voyez youtube est un espace
formidable où se rassemblent des
créateurs unis par la passion
venez sur youtube casse toi